total spending on Capital and revenue on
Railways and only 10 percent of Journey
miles in the country are on Rail and I
just think we have to get that into a
better sense of balance so that's what
we're trying to do with with the unions
I would still urge the unions to
um keep talking
um put those deals to their members at
least a neutral recommendation and call
off the strikes before Christmas which
is going to be so damaging to
individuals and businesses across a
whole range of sectors and the
government will do what we can to try
and encourage both employers and unions
to keep talking so I hope that's helpful
and obviously if you can take some some
questions on that and of course any
other questions the committee wishes to
ask we have a schedule and actually for
anybody watching I think maybe in about
20 minutes time I think we might be
getting on to that particular issue but
thank you very much for that scene
setting and actually leading on to that
my opening question to you is when we
reach the end of this Parliament
presumably around this time in 2024 and
obviously we're assuming that you will
still be in the role hope you will be
what will success look like for you
well I think if I step through the
various areas that the most obvious one
and coming back to where I started is
getting the railway system I think on a
sustainable position
um it's been there's been a massive
impact from covid in terms of the
changed patterns of behavior the fact
that commuter traffic is still only
around 60 percent of what it was
pre-pandemic and I think because of what
people are now able to do with
technology and the change working
patterns I suspect that isn't going to
come back we've seen an increase in
leisure travel so I think the railways
need to be more flexible we need a
proper seven-day Railway uh where we
don't depend on people coming to work
voluntarily and we need a sustainable
long-term position for rail so I think
that that would probably be the first
thing I would say but I'm also very
conscious that the vast majority of
Journeys that people take are either on
roads
um or their active travel they're
walking or something or they're using
buses locally so I think it's also
making sure that as well as the
inevitable conversations we have about
rail which are driven by the current
position the impact of the pandemic and
what the department spends its money on
I'm very conscious we need to make sure
we continue investing in roads we have
to obviously play our part in delivering
our Net Zero Ambitions in decarbonizing
transport across all of the the modes
and ensuring we continue investing in
roads we continue investing in buses and
we make sure that we enable people to
get around so as the final thing is the
government is very clear that we need to
grow the economy we need to improve
economic growth and I think the Autumn
statement and the fact that the
chancellor maintained our budgets both
capital and revenue the government sees
investment in transport as a way of
driving growth in the economy so I think
I think all of those things is how I
would measure whether we're successful
thank you for the clarity there um
obviously you were appointed actually on
my birthday the 25th of October so um
around about six weeks in the job
um just some brief answers really so
there's no need for explanation but what
are your top three immediate priorities
in the role after your first
so I I think the the first thing that's
sort of been thrust into place again and
we'll I won't go into in detail because
we'll come back to it is obviously
dealing with the situation on the
railways partly industrial action and
then connected to that partly the uh the
lack of proper Service delivery on some
some routes that people will know on of
anti-west Coast on tpe so those are
issues which are raised with me both by
colleagues
um and members of the public raise them
as well and you get asked about them
understandably when I met with Northern
Mayors as well
um so that's been one the second one of
course I've referred to the Autumn
statement and whilst the it was very
welcome that we had our budgets
confirmed as with every Department we're
obviously having to manage the impact of
inflation and so we're working through
the settlement that we got in the Autumn
statement and how we're going to
continue delivering our priorities and
that work is underway in the department
and I'm spending a considerable amount
of time on that
um and then and that really is driving
our our other priorities so and then I
suppose the third one is a new secretary
of state is getting my head around the
breadth of the department meeting all of
the the key members of Staff working
with Bernadette and Gareth and their
teams
um and kind of getting my head around
the breadth of the department I suppose
those are my three things that I've been
focused on since I was appointed super
pleased to hear it and I do hope you'll
visit the other offices around the
country of the department
um I enjoyed doing so in the summer
um maybe a question for your two
permanent secretaries um but you might
want to jump in I don't know but
ministerial portfolios and departments
have been significantly reshuffled twice
in the last three months what effect is
this on the continuity continuity of
policy Direction and is there working to
requirement is behind as on schedule as
a result of that well look it's clear
that it's not been ideal that there's
been so much
um you know change in in ministers uh
and portfolios I mean I think it kind of
goes without saying a bit but I think
actually I'm very fortunate I think
we've got a very strong ministerial team
of course this committee will be very
familiar with the rail Minister your
former chair uh I've also got
um a very good military rule team um
baroness via remained as the sort of
institutional memory or the continuity
but I think we've got a very strong team
across the board I've authored the
portfolios and and settled them I think
to match people's skills and I think of
course the blessing of a of a very
strong department at official level and
the way our system works is of course
even with change in the ministerial team
there's been a loss of continuity and
obviously the work that officials have
been carrying forward and so actually as
when I've taken on previous minister
your rules you come into the department
you know you're brought up to speed very
quickly but actually a lot of work goes
on and actually the Department's been
very good I think at identifying key
decisions that needed to be taken
getting them in front of ministers uh
and I think we've we've managed to keep
things going
um quite well I don't know where
Bernadette I would strongly strongly
agree with that I mean inevitably when
we've had a you know fairly extended
period of uncertainty really since the
um start of the leadership election this
summer and then uh changes of ministers
and that causes some sort of um there
are some decisions that absolutely need
to be put in front of ministers and that
ministers need to be confident that they
fully understand before they can take
them so you know there are some areas
where we just need to recognize that
changes in ministers will mean that we
have to we have to take that time and
rightly allow new ministers with new
portfolios to be comfortable with
decision making but we are a department
we are very focused on delivery through
arms length bodies we are very kind of
operational in terms of dealing with
disruption to the transport Network
those sorts of activities
um continue to to proceed and I think we
are able to get on and uh do that
delivery and uh obviously we've always
made sure that when we've had a new
secretary state ministerial team we get
as you say we prioritize the key
decisions get them in front of ministers
at the earliest possible date and keep
cracking on and I think we've been able
to strike uh strike a good balance there
what we do have is obviously the
continuity of the Civil Service teams
and structures behind that so what that
means is you're able to keep the the
institutional knowledge and expertise
focused on areas as Bernadette says on
say delivery of hs2 through to the
transport decarbonization plan or
managing some of the operational issues
we face at the start of summer so that's
been able to keep the continuity as we
brought new ministers up to speed and
made sure they have the opportunity to
shape and direct the department thank
you found a question for me for now um
departmental responses to a number of
consultations across a variety of policy
areas are outstanding so is there a lack
of capacity to see these pieces of work
through or are they imminently about to
be released before Christmas or
immediately in the new year
um I'm not sure well just on on the
reports that are outstanding I know on
the report that the committee did on the
integrated rail plan uh we wrote and
secured an extension to report to
respond fully to next march but we did
commit to providing an update by the end
of the year and we plan to do so on the
report that the committee did on road
pricing that's um going to be responded
to by the treasury
um and they're going to reply in due
course I don't have a specific time as a
member correspondence to the treasury in
the uh indeed and the chancellor so
thank you for that
um Ben
one of the one of the responses we're
still waiting for is the one on pavement
parking which closed two years ago when
when might we see that
yes um I I think a letter came to the
committee to set out that we were
considering that and looking at taking
that forward
um one of the things we're looking at is
our
um uh legislative priorities so that's
not something that's been forgotten I'm
very well aware of it I had it raised
with me in fact when I was a backbencher
as a constituency member of parliament
so it hasn't been forgotten I just don't
have a specific date to come back to the
committee your predecessor who wasn't
there for very long but in that period
did have time to come and see us uh
dropped the bomb Michelle that the
government was dropping the transport
bill but she did she was very clear that
she thought there'd be a narrow small
transport bill is that still the case in
this session is that your expectation I
think I think my predecessor said that
that there wasn't going to be a
transport but in this session there are
clearly things which the department uh
and obviously I will go back and look at
exactly what she said but I think what
she did she said she'd be bringing
forward a narrow transfer middle during
this session right like I I checked what
I what she said I thought she said we'll
check and clarify it but I think she
confirmed to the committee that there
wouldn't be a transport bill this
session but we'll go back and have a
look and confirm
um the the department does obviously
have some legislative
um priorities for the fourth session and
obviously we'll be making our but
setting out our plans for that but
obviously that depends on parliamentary
time being available and that's
decisions are obviously taken across
government when you look at the
government's program on so many of the
issues that are in your Department's
responsibility from pavement parking
which causes misery for millions of our
constituents to the fact that we are
years behind as a country in regulating
e-scooters all of these things that are
holding us back legislation and
regulation on self-driving Vehicles were
also falling years behind our economic
competitors because your department has
failed to do this stuff so when are you
going to do it well I I've made it very
clear Mr Bradshaw we do have a number of
things where we require legislation but
you know as a very experienced
parliamentarian who's also served in
government that decisions about the
legislative program for the full session
are not are not entirely for me I will
set out within government what I
um think are priorities for the
department and then the government as a
whole will conclude about its priorities
and that will be set out in due course
but that isn't entirely a matter for me
much as I wish it were but the
Department's clear about the things that
we wish to prioritize and the committee
will have discussed that with my
predecessor and her predecessor
um but I I it's not it's not within my
gift to set out the legislative
priorities for the full session but
we're very clear all of the things that
you said are things that I want to
achieve and we'll be making that case
very strongly within government what is
it that's preventing the government as a
whole
legislating on these very important
matters meaning that we are being left
behind as a country well I I think it
over the last couple of years it's
fairly obviously the legislative
timetable for the for the entire
parliamentary term
um has been rather transformed by by
events I mean kovid clearly had a
massive impact on the government's
entire program
um and obviously there are other things
going on in the world which have meant
that the government inside government
itself and the constant shopping and
changing of prime ministers and
ministers the inability inability to
agree on the policy and then stick to it
you don't think that's got anything to
do with it no certain things certain
things that you've mentioned there I
don't think are things that have changed
at all but there have been changes
priorities let me just pick up one for
example the government spent a lot of
time over the since the beginning of the
year we've had the Vladimir Putin's war
in Ukraine that's necessitated a very
significant amount of government funding
over a hundred billion pounds being
spent on supporting Energy prices and a
significant amount of government effort
looking at supporting individuals and
there have been a lot of of changes
across government to deal with that that
transformation in the economy and a lot
of time taken up by ministers and in
Parliament dealing with the consequences
of that effect that's not something that
could have been predicted
um an events have impacted on what the
government's focused it's time are you
prepared to commit to addressing these
just those those three issues they're
not huge issues but they're issues that
are of massive concern to our
constituents that we've been waiting for
years on pavement parking e-scooters and
self-drive vehicles will this be done
before the next election well I'm very
clear that those are priorities for my
department but you're very experienced
parliamentary and you know that I do not
have the ability to promise specific
legislation in the full session I will
make my case inside government there are
competing priorities for the government
and decisions will be taken collectively
about our legislative priorities but
those things that you've mentioned are
important priorities for me then I will
be making that case very strongly do you
not see that it yeah it leaves the
impression that the government as a
whole not you because you you fight for
transports interest but the government
as a whole really couldn't care less
about transporting this country no I
strongly disagree I think it's very
clear when you look at what if if you
judge people by putting their money
where their mouth is as a people often
do I think it's very clear from the
Autumn statement and the fact that the
chancellor didn't do what some
governments in the distant past have
done which is to raid Capital spending
to get out of financial
um to plug gaps actually we had our
capital budget confirmed and indeed
Capital budgets were confirmed across
government and our Revenue budget was
confirmed so actually I think the
government's investing in transport very
strongly we've confirmed our investment
in some very significant transport
projects to grow the economy and to get
the economy functioning better
um so actually I'd say the government
was investing in transport and putting
transport very highly as far as
legislation is concerned there are
competing priorities there are lots of
things that are important to our
constituents across a range of factors
the government has to weigh those up I
will be making the case very strongly
for transport but as you know those
decisions are taken collectively across
government and I want to get off on the
right foot with the committee I don't
want to promise the committee things
that I'm not able to deliver things that
are entirely within my control I can
promise I can promise to go and argue
for things inside government but I can't
commit at this stage for fourth term
legislative time for a transport Bill
the kitchen that's very much ben um just
because Ben has asked obviously about
some very searching questions could we
seek some clarification from you and
your two colleagues maybe with some
written statement maybe that we could
have that will give some clarification I
understand it's very difficult for you
in the department to say when
legislation might well be coming forward
but that might just be helpful for all
of us and before I know that we're just
going to ask some questions yes
absolutely on our setup I'll set out
perhaps for the committee uh the
legislation that we've currently got
underway there is some primary
legislation which people may ask about
and other things that the department is
working on for example we're going to
have to spend a fair bit of time on
retained EU legislation to meet the
requirements that are set out in primary
legislation so if we set out perhaps
what the Department's currently working
on and we can set out some of the things
that will need legislation in the future
if that will be helpful to the committee
it will be thank you Ruth well thank you
Secretary of State you say that there's
there's pressure on the legislative
timetable and there are budgets issues
but many of the issues we're waiting for
to see legislation for
um don't involve a lot of spend by the
department and the legislative timetable
is hardly Under Pressure we've got a
longer than normal recess this Christmas
and there's an awful lot of days when
we're not voting on bills so I you know
I we do think there is more to this but
the road safety investigation Branch
hardly uh hardly controversial
does it won't cost a lot of money very
popular will you bring that forward
we're hearing in our self-driving
Vehicles inquiry the the UK industry is
losing out because of the delay in
legislation here so that's got that's
good for for UK business that needs to
come through quickly
um so
um
you say there's a lot of work to do and
certainly there is a lot of work that
you will have to do to review the huge
amount of EU retained law as you said
but will
the UK regulations be updated to World
leading standards or are we going to go
with the Reese smog bonfire of of
regulations and Bob try a red tape in
our attitude to
um to Vehicle Safety which is so
important to so many well there's a
there's a couple of things there just on
your first point about about
parliamentary time you're absolutely
right of course that
um Parliament doesn't spend all of its
time voting or legislation but but
actually in in the same way we're doing
now I mean actually part of what
Parliament does of course is to there is
time made available for opposition day
debates
um back bench debates I mean it's it's
not right that the government consumes
the whole of the Parliamentary timetable
there are some type the legislative all
the time in Parliament is made available
for non-legislative purposes so the
government doesn't have the whole
timetable to itself but I've made it
clear in answer to Mr Bradshaw's
question that there are some priorities
for my department and you're right some
of them don't evolve a huge amount of
spending but they do require legislative
time to get through Parliament and I
will be making that case and very
strongly on your point about regulation
I think one of the things I'm very
mindful of and one of the arguments I
think that all ministers are mindful of
if we can adopt regulation which puts
Britain in a leading position
and sets out a clear framework it's
clearly then of Britain becomes a very
attractive country for getting
investment both from British companies
but also from overseas investors and and
that's where I want to get the country
we've seen some examples of that already
but I want to get to a position on these
issues as Mr Bradshaw set out where we
can actually be leading on these matters
and being attractive inward Investment
location around the world where we can
see these exciting Global steps of all
taking place in Britain that's my
ambition I think it's the government's
ambition actually because we want to
drive economic growth so one of the
arguments I will be making strongly with
colleagues is to exactly legislate to
get that framework and put Britain right
at the front of these important
challenges okay and
in terms of self-driving Vehicles what
discussions are you having with UK firms
who are developing this technology about
the impact of the delay on them
so I I specifically haven't had any
conversations at this point perhaps if I
can ask um Gareth to set out what the
Department's been doing and that may be
helpful sure thank you secretary of
state so we and my team have been
working closely with the industry to
understand the regulatory needs and
particularly working with the law
commission we published a review over
the summer of the need for to understand
particularly things like you know
Insurance the nature the standardized
definitions of autonomy because they're
still changing the industry I saw wave
recently in their Chief exec to
understand exactly the level of where
the technology is I don't know if you've
had the opportunity to go out in some of
their vehicles but it's pretty
impressive what they've been able to
achieve and I think the progress is
faster than a lot of people would have
expected even a few years ago they were
able to set out very clearly what's been
helpful about the UK environment this is
the it's an awful phrase but the
regulatory sandboxes we were created the
future of Mobility zones some of the r d
Investments the the department has been
able to support developments and expand
out to companies like zero Avia as well
on in Aerospace but they're also very
clear about the
standardization and clarification are
needed really to build out the industry
so I think we couldn't be clearer in the
department certainly within my team the
needs of the industry we'd like to think
we've been leading the debate especially
with the law commission which I think is
an incredible work over the summer but
we know obviously that now needs
legislation
thank you
thank you um secretary just listening to
some of your answers um a short while
ago I think the car manufacturing
industry would like to see the country
leading when it comes to legislation
certainly for the period 20 30 35
because I think their view is that we're
actually lagging behind at this point
the EU and the rest of the world were
leading from the front but that maybe
comes in the clarification about What
legislation might be coming forward if
that's okay and also I'm particularly
going to draw your attention to the fact
that your predecessor and what she said
when she was in front of this committee
and what you've referred to I think that
we are right and unfortunately I think
your department is wrong but we'll leave
that for another day is that okay so
moving on to Great British Railways uh
Chris good morning everybody nice to see
you uh again and Gareth particularly um
secretary of state is it still your uh
your plan to fully implement the plan
for rail I.E Great British railways so
uh it's very much my plan to um achieve
what the intention behind that idea
which is to get the railways um to have
a to have a a guiding mind behind them
to to have a more integrated position
between
um how the different parts of the
industry work and what I wanted to do
was take some time as you know there are
different views about how exactly we
achieve that
um not just outside Parliament but also
inside Parliament so I wanted to take
some time not too much time but I wanted
to take some time to listen to those
alternative views from some of those
that have held the rail brief in the
past and others so I've I've started
that work I've
um spoken to Mr Williams I've spoken to
a number of colleagues who've got views
on this matter
um and I will and talking to my
colleague the rail Minister and we'll
reach some conclusions so I haven't done
yet but I wanted to some time to make
sure we make the right decisions what
we're saying then is that the Great
British Railways proposal as it stands
currently is up in the air well I'm
taking some time to just reflect on it
and to make sure when we move forward
that I'm entirely happy with what we're
doing and I know there are a range of
views in Parliament and I think it's
important that I take some time to
listen
um and bear those in mind before I make
any final decisions
we've just heard from you a little bit
earlier about the ability to progress
primary legislation
it feels as though that certainly in
this session it's going to be impossible
to fully Implement gbr as has been set
out even though at our last session
it was made clear to us that the
legislation required
to fully Implement gbr will be
relatively short and not complicated and
that I think we are clear that
legislative ability for primary
legislation is not going to be possible
in this session
what are the what are actually the
options available and what realistically
are you considering on changing
well
I've obviously said an answer to Mr
Bradshaw's question that we'll look at
um legislation for the the full session
but there are of course things that we
can do without legislation which we are
aren't continuing to work on so we've
made some commitments about rolling out
contactless pay as you go
um ticketing to more stations in the
Southeast that work is underway we've
already got the gbr transition team
working so so we've already got some of
the
could have just come back of course my
understanding is that contactless travel
and ticketing was contracted some time
ago and that was a that's totally
separate to this
um that there are I understand many
hundreds of people working on gbr as it
stands today at the taxpayers expense
um we're in this situation where clearly
decisions need to be made very quickly
and I wonder whether you could just
share with us when you're likely to make
that very clear decision to as to what
extent gbr will be implemented well
we've already brought
um the the transition team together so
it's already the case that we've got uh
Network Rail and DFT teams working all
closely together to look at how you
align the business planning between
track and train which is one of the
things that we need to do so there's
already a lot of bringing people
together working together uh underwear
already and I'll ask the permanent
secretary says a little bit more about
that in in a minute there are things
that you do need legislation for
um and we'll be making that case as I
said same answer I'm afraid as the one I
gave Mr Bradshaw which is I can't commit
to doing that but clearly there is work
that can be done ahead of legislation
and of course a lot of planning can take
place and I'm on on your final
point before I ask the parent secretary
to comment
um in terms of making decision I I aim
to do that at PACE but I do also just
want to say and given what I said in my
remarks about the amount of resource
that the department spends on Rail and
the importance of rail I want to make
sure that we make the right decisions
and I think given I've only been in this
role a few weeks I just want to take the
time to get it right before we move
ahead with it um Bernadette did you just
want to say a bit about the
absolutely so
um we had this discussion of course Mr
loader as the last touring as well and I
think I did confirm then that
legislation would be relatively
um short
um uh as of when it's brought forward
and as we discussed then there are some
things which you require legislation in
order to change fundamentally including
who is the formal franchising Authority
however as the secretary of state has
indicated a great deal of the sort of
purpose and sort of intent of that rail
reform set out in the white paper can be
taken forward without legislation
um steps to improve and roll out extend
flexible ticketing steps to drive
Workforce reform other measures uh to to
just ensure that the railway is
operating more effectively and
efficiently in the interests of
taxpayers and passages there are many
things that don't require legislation
and colleagues in my department in
network rail Etc and in the industry we
are working together to drive those
improvements as far and as effectively
as we can with or without legislation so
that work does does indeed continue my
understanding is the only thing that's
really required in legislative terms is
the franchising Authority change
that's correct so
um given that this process started if I
recall correctly back in 2017 under the
then Secretary of State the member for
Epsom and Yule
um we are some five years down the line
um
given we have many hundreds of people
working on this at considerable expense
do you have a timeline to which you are
working for certain Milestones to be
delivered even if it's not the full
Suite of the the original proposal yes
there are still plans within the
department for taking forward the
various work streams that I've described
that don't require legislation and
obviously we will work with the
secretary of state and under his
direction to ensure those are taken
forward in a way that he is satisfied is
is right yeah thank you
um the rail networking enhancements plan
the rnep could you tell us when we're
going to see that please yeah so as I
said in my answer earlier one of the
things that we're now doing in the
department and we're doing this at some
considerable uh effort and pays is to
work through both our capital and our
Revenue plans following the awesome
statement so one of the things I'm doing
with my ministerial team is looking at
how we manage the as I said we had our
capital and our Revenue budgets
confirmed but obviously we are having to
deal with as all government departments
are and indeed the private sector the
inflation pressures so we're looking at
our Capital Investments and looking at
the priorities on those and we will set
out I I know that some of these things
haven't been published for some time we
will set all of those out when we've
reached conclusions on our Capital are
you coming under particular pressure
from the treasury to find savings no
well as I said budgets were confirmed in
cash terms but of course there are
significant inflation priorities that we
have to manage and we're working through
those priorities now with my ministerial
team across all of the areas of capital
expenditure and all the areas of Revenue
as I said the information in terms of
our total expenditure was set out at the
Autumn statement and those those numbers
are as they were set out in the spending
review but there are some priorities
that we need to to adjust at this moment
I'm not able to indicate when we'll see
the r-nep coming forward or confirmed no
it's Our intention to publish it when
we've reached conclusions but we're
obviously working that through following
the Autumn statement thank you I'd just
like to move on to the next section if
I'm a chairman
um thank you thank you uh disruption on
the railways
um Secretary of State your predecessor
sent us a letter on the 20th of October
I want to say centers I don't mean the
committee I mean members of parliament
um outlining the transport strikes
minimum service levels bill and the
intentions uh could you tell us when we
can expect the second reading of that to
come forward to the House of Commons
yeah so as you know and from the way
that letter was set out the bill has
been introduced in Parliament
um it hasn't yet had a a second reading
um I can't give the committee a specific
time on that but I would just say as
I've said publicly on that
um that that may well be that
legislation a lead to an improvement in
the medium to long term but of course
that legislation however fast it's
progressed given that it's got to go
through both the House of Commons and
the House of Lords is not a solution to
dealing with
industrial action we see at the moment
the other thing I would say is whilst
that legislation May well improve the
service that passengers receive on
strike days I think my priority is to
try and ensure that we can resolve the
industrial dispute so that passengers
don't have strike days rather than
achieving that's how you get better
service to passengers is to resolve the
disputes rather than have a slightly
better service on strike days I should
have I should have declared chairman I
apologize I as a former member of the
rmt and former employee of the railways
I'm sorry I didn't do that that's really
accepted and you're admonished so are we
then saying that that legislation
actually has little value at all no I'm
saying that
if if it's not going to affect the
situation today
particularly the coming weeks because
we're seeing considerable strike action
is that bill actually valuable
so I'm saying that that built two things
I think but both of those things are
true the bill absolutely May well
contribute value in the future
um but it's clearly given that it would
have to go through Parliament there's uh
if you look at the way the Bill's
drafted there then has to be some
agreement and some secondary legislation
and quite a bit of work has to take
place even when the bills on the statute
book it's clearly not going to be
something that's going to help with the
industrial action that we face today and
one of the reasons as I set out in my
opening statement why I felt it
important to meet with the Trade union
leaders and to try and help facilitate
working with the rail Minister
[Music]
better talks between both sides the
Employers in the unions is to try and
get us to a resolution of the present
industrial dispute conscious that it's
going to lead to terrible means for
passengers there are many many millions
of people who are adversely affected by
these strikes
we have here in Parliament uh when
necessary push through legislation quite
quickly and it can be done is it no
longer the government's intention to
push this through uh rapidly and are
they reconsidering it
so you're right usually legislation that
is pushed through rapidly tends to have
to be pushed through uh when there's
cross-party agreements on that
legislation and there's
um and that I don't think is the case
here
um but look it is my uh firm intention
to try and get to a position where we
can resolve the industrial dispute
you're absolutely right it's going to
cause enormous inconvenience for
passengers particularly over Christmas
it's also going to create create
tremendous inconvenience for many
businesses and I'm very conscious for
example with the hospitality industry
you know who the last couple of
Christmas periods have suffered
tremendously because of covert this was
going to be the first
Christmas period which is very busy for
the industry that they were going to be
able to trade normally and I'm I'm very
disappointed that they're going to be
damage which is why I call on the you
know news unions even at this stage to
cool off those strikes of Christmas but
all I'm saying is the legislation
um this isn't going to be a solution to
the industrial design today I'm going to
get it kicking for time but I just
wanted to finally ask you then
um given you met with unions only last
week and the rmt particularly has
continued to call for more strikes um
it's the real value in the meetings that
you have with uni leaders if they're
just going to continue to call for
strike action well I always think it's
better to keep talking than not talking
it's always good to have those channels
of communication I found the meetings
that they were constructive meetings I
think the government did what we said we
were going to do we said we would help
facilitate communication between unions
and employers and actually following my
meeting the employers made a revised
offer which I think most people looking
at it given that it involves a
reasonable Fair pay settlement
protection against compulsory
redundancies for a period And it but it
does insist on necessary Workforce
reform I think most people would think
that was fair One Trade union is putting
that deal at the network rail deal to
its members with a recommendation to
accept that's why I would hope the rmt
would do even at this stage looking at
the inconvenience that they're going to
cause passengers and businesses but I
think keeping talking keeping those
channels of communication open is a good
thing rather than the opposite and just
before I hand over to Jack to ask you
about some of the issues in the north
it's our understanding that the
department offered a derogation which
was taken to Southeastern Railway and
Southwestern Railway about its timetable
changes
um could you tell us uh maybe why that
is and whether or not they will continue
their derogations going forward will
continue look I I think the derogation
you're talking about is about whether
there was a consultation
about that I may just ask the permanent
secretary to come into a lot since that
was a decision taken before I was in the
department uh it was I think the case
that
um previous ministers concluded that
some timetable changes as should not be
formally consulted upon so I think your
your question is is accurate the
question is will that continue are you
going to continue to change the
timetables without content I think that
will be a matter for
um ministers current ministers so no
that was that was I mean you
specifically referred to the Past
decision I think going forward
um we'll look at those circumstances
I'll make decisions on that based on all
of the circumstances and it'll depend
it'll depend on Case by case basis I
think
thank you Chris before we come to Jack
I'm going to come to Graham but before
come to Graham's got two quick fire
questions for you of course
um your predecessor told us you plan to
review and consultant ticket offices
imminently is that still the
Department's plan
it is still the case that we are looking
at
um the way ticket officers operate one
of the things we're talking to the trade
unions part of the discussions is about
reforming the way they work very few
people now there's only about 12 percent
I think of ticket purchases um are done
in ticket offices one of the
frustrations is you've got staff who are
then in those ticket offices not
actually able to be used uh front of
house to serve passengers so one of the
things that we're just that the
employers are talking to unions about is
having those staff uh retrained able to
come out of the ticket offices
but 12 is still one-eighth of the
population that might be elderly
population who like dealing in cash yes
it is no and we we absolutely want to
make sure that those people that want to
deal in cash and need to engage
physically with purchasing tickets are
still able to but clearly you don't want
to put as much resource into ticket
offices and tying the staff to purely
work in a ticket office when you've seen
the number of tickets being purchased
going down from I think a third to only
just over 10 so I think you need to have
Workforce reform and it's about
delivering a better experience to
passengers to make sure those staff are
able to to work flexibly selling tickets
when that is required but also able to
to assist customers in stations
particularly vulnerable and disabled
customers who need other sorts of uh
assistance Mr no no you refer to the
fact that we'd all like to see the
intended industrial action um over the
Christmas period not take place but what
consideration have you given for
clarification did a fair implant
Christmas engineering works if any so
one of the things that Network rail is
is now looking at given the
um strikes that were called uh by the
rmt or network rail is looking at that
120 million pounds worth of essential
maintenance work to see the extent to
which that's affected and of course even
though that may not impact passenger
Services it absolutely will affect the
reliability of the Railway and of course
it's done at Christmas because although
I recognize it sometimes causes
inconvenience to people at Christmas it
is done then because that is the least
busy time to do it if that work isn't
done at the Christmas period it means it
will have to be done at other times of
the year which will cause more
inconvenience to passengers so Network
rail is working through what changes it
may have to take place with its
engineering work in response to the
strike action that's been called by the
rmt first time we have a number of
questions and lots more to get through
so I'm going to move on to Graham Morris
thanks chair and and good morning to uh
you've said the panel I've got a couple
of questions on the real dispute and uh
um a couple of observations as well but
um
it's in relation to your comments there
about the
um the um proposed minimum standards uh
rail bill which will be hugely
controversial I don't think anyone's in
any doubt that will completely sour
industrial relations at a time when
we're trying to build a a settlement but
why is it secretary of state that
there's time for this controversial
piece of legislation it's been driven by
your department and yet apparently there
isn't time to do to deal with quite a
number of issues identified by my
colleagues regarding pavement parking
regarding the regulation of e-scooters
of autonomous vehicles and so on where
there is a cross-party agreement that we
need to crack on with these it seems it
seems slightly perverse that we can find
time for one hugely controversial piece
of legislation and not for another
well I I take a couple of these first of
all Mr Morris I think you've um
confirmed what I was implying in in my
answer to Mr loader which is that taking
that legislation forward rapidly
um the minimum service levels
legislation would would not be possible
since there wouldn't be a cross-party
agreement and you you need that if we
have to Shorter answers without
repetition would be really helpful
because we've got a lot together so
let's answer this question yeah yes of
course I I look I I I it's a balance Mr
Bradshaw I'm trying to give full answers
but I said if you wish me to move a
little more yeah
um so I welcome that on on your issue
about balancing these things off that
legislation of course was already
introduced in this session the The Wider
transport bill
um my predecessor I think confirmed it
wouldn't be taking place this session
um and I've made it clear in answer to
my earlier question that it is it's got
a range of things in it which are
priorities for me but I need to make
that case with colleagues in government
I understand you to explain that earlier
I appreciate that and can I ask now
particularly about the real dispute I I
do support your your philosophy of
continuing to talk and I'm heartened by
the fact that the um the real Freight
operating companies
um the Scottish government the Welsh
government and I think the the urban
access train operating companies have
all reached settlements with the real
unions so it must be possible it's not
an impossible task to to achieve a
settlement but they haven't placed
preconditions in relation to ticket
office closures or the acceptance of
driver only operated trains
uh is there any Prospect of continuing
to uh
um continuing the talks to secure such a
settlement
um if these preconditions are attached
well I I don't want to get too far into
specific details because I do think it's
important that negotiations take place
between the employers and the unions and
and I think both sides accept that on
the more on the the overall stance
though I do think it's important that
this isn't just a dispute about about
pay it is a dispute also about
modernizing the railway and having
Workforce reform and as I said in in my
opening statement I think I captured I
do think in order for the railways to
have a sustainable future we do have to
see reform in the way they operate it
isn't going to be sustainable for the
taxpayer to continue to put in the sums
it has put in without seeing that reform
it's the reform generates the savings
that help fund the pay rise and I think
both of those things are part of the the
debate but I think keeping talking is
very valuable but you said I'm sure the
trade unions appreciate that no over a
long period of time the first job I ever
had I was a member of the Nui even even
before my colleague Chris Lauder was a
twinkle
I was I was a member
and before it was the rmt but but you
know and over a long period of time
they've accepted changes modernization
reforms and so on but one of the things
that that we've identified as a
committee in relation to another inquiry
we're doing about access for disabled
people are the concerns about if there
are
um a closure of ticket offices if there
are stations without staff if there are
driver only operated trains how this
will how does that square with our
commitment under the equality in human
rights
um commission requirements to ensure the
disabled and elderly and vulnerable
people can access the the railways and
is that not a factor in your
negotiations is a more gradual approach
not more more likely to to be beneficial
because we have to address these legal
considerations
sorry yes look look on the general point
I do want to make sure the railways are
very accessible you may well know um in
my ministerial history I was the
minister for disabled people I take this
very seriously it's one of the reasons
in setting out portfolios for my
ministerial team I've made sure everyone
has a responsibility to deliver
accessible transport
so part of the reason what all the
government said is that we need to see
that reform it is important that the
detail of that reform how you deliver it
the time scale over which you deliver it
and the flexibility of the staff and
making sure there's proper service for
customers is very important that's why
the detail needs to be hammered out
between the employers both on on the
points you're talking about the train
operating companies and the unions the
detail needs to be hammered out but I
think the principle of Reform is very
valuable you know in answer to my
question on ticket office I made point
you don't want people tied to sitting
behind a desk not serving very many
customers I want them to be able to also
to serve customers in the station the
detail of how that works is for the
unions and the employers to hammer out
between them which is why I want to see
them continuing to talk to reach an
agreement that they feel that the unions
can then recommend to their members I
just want to very quickly refer to or
not I'm not a telegraph one reader I
must confess but there is an article in
the telegraph today which suggests that
the treasury or number 10 are insisting
on a precondition before the
negotiations where can move forward of
the Union's accepting driver only
operation I I don't know what the time
frame is or if that's just in principle
but are you in a position to confirm or
deny that that report's correct well I I
haven't seen the report so I I can't
really comment on it I haven't seen it
on the specific point about about driver
only operation we've obviously seen that
on on quite a significant part of the
Railway or lady so I don't think there's
an in principle objection to it I know
that it is controversial
um but but you know it's something that
exists on the railways already in terms
of what I want to see I mean I want the
two sides to continue talking the
government has facility I was asked to
facilitate
um an improved offer it was made clear
to me when I met Mr Lynch that you know
on the train operating side I hadn't
been an offer there now has been an
offer I would urge the two sides to
continue talking the unions to call off
the strikes I think that's the right
thing for passengers and I think it's
also the right thing for the foreign
yeah you you can't claim you didn't see
the splash on Monday in the Daily
Telegraph claiming number 10 at the last
minute is added driver-only trains is an
issue to just this dispute was that
report incorrect well I I was
specifically talking Mr Morris asked me
a question about a report today which I
I haven't it was on Monday on the
general the second shift state did you
not see this report and is it true
no that I've been very clear that we've
uh I was asked to facilitate the issue
of offer driver-only trains been
introduced by the number 10 or the
treasury at the last minute it wasn't on
the table on reform we're very clear no
answer the question we're very close we
need to see reform the question on the
specifics about detail detailed
negotiations are taking place between
employers and trade unions it's not the
government's role to micromanage the
detail of the reform so but we've been
clear that we do need to see work
operators and the unions both say that
this issue has been inserted in the last
week by number 10 or the treasury which
has scuppered a deal that was on the
table well that is what the both the
train operators and the unions just on
that point about scuffing a deal when
that was already on the table when I met
um Mr Lynch he made it very clear to me
that he hadn't had an offer on the trade
operating side of the house there had
been an offer on network rail
um I met with the trade unions I was
asked to facilitate an improvement we
then saw what was that question
well I am telling you what's been going
on there was then an improved offer to
the unions from Network Rail and an
offer then came on the train operating
side of the house that the unions could
consider I regret that they rejected
that offer I think it would have been
better if they'd continue talking to try
and Hammer out some detail I haven't
been
why do you think Scotland and Wales have
settled there haven't been why do you
think they've there haven't been
preconditions yes there needs to be
reform I've been very clear you have to
have reform to drive the savings
um and I'm telling you what's going on
I'm not going to give a provide a
running commentary um
yeah we're rewarding the question I mean
the public wants to know what's going on
here they have a right to know if number
10 intervened to stop a deal by adding
driver only trains at the last minute
which is what the companies not the
unions the companies they happen no one
is trying to stop a deal quite the
reverse I met with the trade unions I I
felt that conversation was important
um and actually we then saw a a more an
improved deal coming on both sides both
the train operating companies and
network rail we're trying to reach a
deal here it's the trade unions that
have rejected all the rmt that's
rejected I think that's regrettable and
I've said it's very disappointing from
the point of view of passages I'm very
clear I want to see a deal reached I
think we could have always avoided the
Christmas Chaos number 10 have now
guaranteed Christmas Chaos
not even answering the questions
will show you've asked your questions
the secretaries
thank you then question you might not
like the answer but there is a fair and
reasonable offer on the table and I
think it's regrettable that the rmt is
going ahead with strikes rather than
putting that offer to its member thank
you Ben Secretary of State we're moving
on a little bit behind time but Jack
thank you very much for your patience
the floor is yours Mr chair and firstly
why is it that rail services are
particularly so bad in in the north and
parts of the Midlands
well the the the reason for the recent
um downturn in in uh performance it is
is largely not not entirely but but
largely to do with the fact that
um there's been two two issues I think
partly if it's been a driver shortage uh
which occurred as a result of the
pandemic and the fact that there was a
lack of driver training so that's been
that's been one of the causes
um we've worked the Department's worked
closely with the uh train operating
companies to get those drivers trained
and we've seen a significant increase in
driver availability which has improved
matters the other issue is that this
comes back to the need for Workforce
Workforce reform too much of the
timetable is dependent on what's called
rest day working which is where drivers
have to volunteer to work on days in
order to deliver a timetable that means
that the railway is not very sustainable
because if those drivers stop working on
those rest days you end up with Trains
being canceled at the last minute and a
very flaky and unreliable service and
that is what we have seen
on both transpennine Express and Olive
anti-west coast and that's not
acceptable so one of the things that
Avanti is going is we're expecting them
to do with their new December timetable
which kicks in on the 11th of December
there'll be a very significant increase
in the searches that they're offering
the only the only tragedy for passengers
and I heard this loud and clear when I
met with Northern Mayors last week the
tragedy is because of the industrial
action that improved timetable which
would both have more services more
reliably delivered passengers are not
going to see the benefit of that because
almost as soon as that new timetable
kicks in there's going to be a set of
national industrial actions so again
another reason why I hope it stopped so
I want to part the reason why we need
Workforce reform is to get rid of this
Reliance on rest day working to have a
proper seven-day Railway so that we have
a reliable service for all of those
people that need a reliable train
service whether it's to get to work to
see members of their family or to do all
the important things that they have to
do and I think that would that would
help secure the long-term future of the
Railway as you've suggested of Anthony
are proposing to increase their number
of trains every day from 180 to 264. do
you have any confidence that they'll be
able to actually run those trains
well if I just let me just put aside and
I'll try to keep Mr Bradshaw happy not
repeat myself
um putting aside industrial action if
the industrial action wasn't taking
place
then um I do think they would be able to
deliver that there has been a a
significant number of new drivers I
think they're able to deliver that
timetable previously I just promised in
October that we would see uh with the
September uh changes to the timetable
that we would see near enough return of
full services and that failed to
materialize so we have been here and
seen this before haven't we so why
should we now assume that from December
to the time December timetable changes
that we are actually going to see all of
these trains uh being restored well uh
let me answer that first and then I may
just ask Bernadette to comment on the
the previous yeah invitation so we've
been working very closely with the
Department with the company to test you
know the drivers that they have
available the robustness of whether they
think they can of whether we think they
can deliver that timetable
um we think they can
um as I said that the difficulty is and
I I'm very clear I want to hold of anti
to account to deliver the services that
they've promised for passengers one of
the difficulties I can hold them to
account for things they can control
um the thing that's the thing that's
going to stop me being able to do that
is is the um industrial action because
um they're going to perfectly reasonably
be able to turn around if they don't
deliver that timetable and point to the
industrial action so I want a period
where we don't have industrial action
where we can hold them to account
they've made some clear commitments we
think they can deliver those commitments
and I want to see them deliver those for
passengers but but they're clearly not
going to deliver those commitments if
two days after they roll out the new
timetable we see
um four days of industrial action
and Bernadette do you want to just
comment on Mr raritan's yeah reasonable
point on the September timetable indeed
and I think In fairness um I think we
are stress testing these plans
recognizing that sort of over-promising
and under delivering only sort of
exacerbates the
um a frustration that passengers and
people feel about Services I think a lot
more work has been done now to deal with
the backlog of driver training and to
reduce the Reliance on risk day working
which is why uh we believe this should
be a more
um deliverable uh now proposition uh so
uh and I think lessons have been learned
by the company and
um certainly my department working with
the company to ensure that is the case
um as the secretary of state rightly
says uh industrial action will uh will
prevent those service levels from being
delivered there is also an ongoing I
think issue which I know the company is
working uh hard with as left on to
ensure that aslef is cooperating on
rosters as well so it is also dependent
upon that so you but let's say certainly
my department has been working closely
with the vanity to make sure that this
new timetable is one which they can
effectively deliver
s have seen uh in terms of the number of
trains on time has been less than half
uh so you know the the previous
Secretary of State didn't take the
contract off of anti do you think that
decision was a mistake
yeah so look I I had I've had quite
strong opinions expressed to me both by
by colleagues in Parliament and also
when I met the northern Mayors last week
about what they think should happen to
the the contract and I and I asked them
for example to write to me to set out
their views with with the evidence
um I'm focused on delivering better
services for passengers I mean decisions
will be taken in due course about what
happens to the contract I think at the
moment the the best thing we can do is
to hold is to try and get them to
deliver against their
um uh promises as I said we have been
stress testing and kicking the tires on
their promises
um the the reduced Reliance on rest day
working the increased number of drivers
so we think they can deliver these
promises I mean the proof of the pudding
will be in the eating but uh it is going
to be disrupted by the industrial action
so but I'm very focused I've heard from
from colleagues who use that service
I've heard from members of the public
I've heard from others who engage with
it and of course it's worth saying that
the regime that these companies get paid
under there's a small amount which is a
fixed fee but a bigger amount is based
on their performance and that's
independently assessed and that
determines how much money they earn from
the contract so the company is very well
aware but if it doesn't deliver it it
that will impact the amount of money
that it receives protecting a potential
Financial penalties on Avanti and on uh
transpennai well the way the contract is
set up there's a half a percentage is a
is a fixed fee but one and a half
percent of of of the fee is based on
their performance and that's
independently assessed so if they don't
deliver the things they say they're
going to deliver then that will
materially impact the fee they get from
the department for running those
services so they're very well aware of
that and I'm very well aware of the
service at the moment is simply not
acceptable for customers who aren't able
to rely on it at the moment and I'm very
clear if we're going to to have a
long-term future for the railway need a
reliable service that passengers can
count on in every part of the country
many passengers have been impacted by
very short-term changes as well less
than 48 hours in some cases of timetable
changes tickets not being available for
sale at all in some cases so have you
looked at the wider implications of this
you know the social the economic
implications of this decision because of
how short term and how significant the
impacts have been on on passengers yes I
have I'm very conscious and I've
listened to to many of the the stories
about how people have been impacted that
you know not having a reliable service
having trains canceled at short notice
when people then can't change their
Journeys very easily it has a massive
impact on people's ability to go to work
people's ability to attend important
appointments to attend education and and
impact a lot on businesses as well and
people being able to travel to you know
large events for example that was a
point made very strongly to me when I
met my
Northern Mayors last week they made a
very strong point about the impact on
their Regional economy which is why I
think it's so very important that we get
those Services being delivered as they
should be and as promised
in terms of network rail as well and Ben
and I hosted the oor yesterday for a
briefing with parliamentarians and the
aor have raised quite a lot of concerns
about Network rails performance as well
every region of network rail has been
performing worse than they did
previously in terms of the delays that
they are causing to the rail industry so
what are you doing to ensure that
Network rail are performing and
addressing these issues that we're
seeing so I mean one of the issues of
course is to try and get network Rail
and the train operating companies to
work more closely together so part of
you know going back to my answer to Mr
loader part of what we're doing is
trying to get those two parts of the
industry to work more closely together
um and I'm very conscious that we need
to reduce the the impact and it's part
of the reason why it's going to be
disappointing that we don't get as much
of the maintenance work done over the
Christmas period because you need to do
it when the railway is less busy so that
you have a more reliable Railway and one
of the things I took into account when
we signed off the
um high level output specification and
the
a periodic review budget that we just
signed off was to make sure we continue
investing in today's Railway to keep up
the quality and the performance of the
network as well as investing in new
Railways so that's one of the things
that I will keep a continuing focus on I
don't know whether the permanent
secretary wants to add anything to me
well I'm just going to interrupt it as
you as you're asking your your colleague
and Secretary of State unconscious it
has gone half ten we are still on rail
we have a lot to get okay so brevity in
answers but colleagues particularly
brevity in questions please as we move
forward of course okay
I don't think I have a great deal to add
to what the Secretary of State said I
mean I certainly would emphasize I'm not
sure what the particular issues uh
around performance overall uh were
raising with you and colleagues
yesterday were
um
they've stated very clearly that uh in
their latest figures that every single
one of the five regions of network rail
um are performing worse than they were
um and this is having an impact on
um the the delays of services and so
this is the maintenance the normal
maintenance and renewal type of activity
um so first thing I would say is there
has been an absolute transformation
already in the way that Network rail
works with operators over recent years
and that is continuing I can certainly
remember when I was first involved in
rail network Rail and operators were
sort of often warring factions and I
think uh there is now enormous
cooperation and uh joint planning uh
things like Works to minimize disruption
and generally speaking I think NRL
perform is very very much better than it
has historically in those areas
obviously where there's a deterioration
in performance then we expect our Roar
to hold them took out and we in the
department will hold them to account to
clearly NR themselves have also been
impacted by industrial action which will
not have improved performance in uh in
recent months what are you doing to try
and get network rail to work more
collaboratively with local partners with
other organizations because we've seen
as Secretary of State News some serious
problems with trying to deliver
transforming cities fund investment in
Stoke-on-Trent what are you doing to
make sure that Network rail are obliged
to work with local authorities with
other local key stakeholders to actually
deliver the public transport
improvements that we need to see
I think the regional structure that
Network rail now has was precisely
introduced uh in order to ensure that
there is that much more effective
working the NR I mean it is true again
historically and I was something of a
sort of sort of national monolith and I
know that local stakeholders I used to
find it very frustrating engaging with
NR and it may not be perfect and I'm
sure there's always room for improvement
but the regional structure
um now is absolutely designed to ensure
that the sort of focus of the leadership
team within our NR is absolutely on
building that closer engagement with
local stakeholders and partners and
operators and also thinking about those
wider questions you rightly say about
integration with other forms of
Transport so I think uh I think uh some
very significant steps and improvements
have been made in recent years but I
don't think n on if Andrew Haynes was
here I don't think he'd claim that there
is no room for con for further
Improvement
I want to move on now to discuss a bit
about rail infrastructure and
particularly around Northern Powerhouse
Rail and the proposals for Northern
Powerhouse Trail and the uh option one
was selected by the government and uh
but transport is transport for North
least preferred option so why is it that
option one has been selected by the
government
well the
commitment that we've made to Northern
Powerhouse rail the core network is
remains as it was set out in the
integrated rail plan and the chancellor
confirmed in I mean one of the first
questions I got asked this was one of
the first sets of questions I got asked
when I was appointed to this role the
Chancellor's confirmed that we're
committed to delivering
um the core Northern Powerhouse rail
network clearly I have already you know
found in this job there are lots of
people with views about how we do that
um exactly how we lay it out one of the
conversations I had last week with
Northern Mayors was was there a range of
views about how we take on the further
stages
um and we continue to listen to them but
the core Northern Powerhouse rail
network as set out in the engagement
rail plan Remains the government's
commitment that we're committed to
delivering are you still undertaking
work to reappraise options for Northern
power Australia so we're looking at
we've set out what we're planning on
doing there are things we are going to
continue to look at so
um the Prime Minister made some
commitments about how we deliver
high-speed services to Bradford and we
shall continue looking at how we do that
so there are still things that we're
looking at but the core network is the
commitment that we've set out in the
integrated rail plan and that remains so
you haven't got a firm option yet
well
should I just say because I think your
question was about why the proposals
that are currently in the integrated
rail plan were those uh those were
chosen which I think a few dates uh
we're trying specifically States whether
you are still you know focused on this
option one that you put forward as the
proposals
um through the integrated rail plan is
is that now the option or is there still
work underway to reappraise and look at
Alternatives these are still there's
just still the same core plan as the
secretary of state has said uh
connectivity to Bradford is something
which I know he wants to look at and the
Prime Minister has indicated he wishes
to do uh but there is not now a sort of
reopening of uh the core elements of the
integrated rail plan obviously in
putting that plan together uh previous
government was balancing on the one hand
the need for the desire to make it very
very significant and transformational
investment uh in rail in the north with
the broader uh demands of sort of
affordability
um that is what the plan does
um if all of the uh you may recall it's
a 96.4 billion plan I think the national
infrastructure commission commission
um calculated that if if the government
had done everything that all
stakeholders had asked for including
transport for the north it would have
been 185 billion pound plan and
obviously
um that was uh judged to be unaffordable
so it's a balance between say commitment
to transformational uh investment and
also needing to take a realistic view of
what what is what is Affordable in the
long term with the development of hs2
there's going to be increasing Focus now
obviously the Eastern leg is there's
change plans there there's going to be
an increasing Reliance upon Services
running onto the existing Network onto
the classic Network so what are you
doing to ensure that the investment
that's needed because there is
investment that's needed on the classic
Network to facilitate those hs2 trains
for example it leads also my own area in
Stoke-on-Trent we need some investment
in the classic Network what are you
doing to make sure that Network rail are
actually putting forward that investment
to facilitate hs2 Services well two
things I think it's worth saying that um
and
um Mr loader talked about the our net
plan it's worth just saying I think that
the investment in the
non-hs2 rail network the capital
spending the the bulk of that is going
to be taking place outside London and
the southeast so actually there's been a
a rebalancing of where we spend our rail
capital investment that's not hs2 to
spread that more fairly across the whole
country so there'll be very significant
investment in the the north of England
and one of the things that we're very
clear about is making sure that we look
at hs2 and network rails plans together
to make sure that that they interact
properly as I said but the the core
network is what we've set out in the
integrated rail plan and that remains
the government's position and and yes I
know there are many people that would
have liked to have settled on different
plans but it's about balancing the
investment and I think it's worth saying
which you know a lot of focus goes on
the things that we're not doing and the
things that people didn't get but it is
worth just saying that you know as I
said at the beginning we are maintaining
our 20 billion pound investment in
capital on transport which is a very
significant piece of investment and the
government's maintaining its investment
in infrastructure so I would I would
continue to argue that you know it's a
very significant driver of economic
growth and a very significant commitment
to all parts of the UK or on this
government on Transportation final
question I just wanted to ask to relate
to that is about the methodology that's
used to assess projects and there are a
lot of concerns about this that have
been raised previously about you know
how it's able to fully capture the
benefits particularly for those areas
where leveling up is more important and
capture those uh the the ability of that
growth potential
um are you concerned and do you think
that the department have still got this
right in terms of the methodology that
is being used and that this will you
know deliver on the leveling of
aspirations of the government
so you're right to highlight the
leveling up aspirations to the
government one of the reasons why we're
we're committed to the the core Northern
Powerhouse rail network it's exactly to
join up
um the cities of the north to to get
those agglomeration benefits
um I think the Department's got from
from my experience of it so far the
department I think it's got a very good
team of analysts who try and pull all of
this information together
um to try and weigh up and balance all
of these projects
um you can do a lot of that I mean to
some extent you always have to put some
judgment in it and the government's
going to have some strategic priorities
I think it has to take all the
analytical work all of the attempt to
boil these things down to numbers but
there is some judgment involved about
what our strategic priorities are so I
think you have to weigh those things up
and that's why decisions are taken by
ministers because you've got a lot of
data but ultimately there's some
strategic judgment to take as well can I
just add a word on this um I know the
Department's kind of analytical called
modeling and our transport appraisal
methodology is often challenged just to
say firstly we are constantly seeking to
improve and evaluate I think it is
actually a very good analytical set of
tools
um it is very important it's something
we value and put a lot of effort into in
the department we're constantly seeking
to improve already within our modeling
we are very conscious and we explicitly
identify the fact there are always going
to be wider impacts which cannot be
Quantified and that is very much part of
our decision making process to
acknowledge and recognize those wider
impacts as the secretary of state is
indicating what the government is also
now doing is putting more weight on the
Strategic case
alongside a sort of standard business
case in making the decisions that it
does about
um about these Investments and I do
think particularly for these very large
long-term and transformational
Investments that's uh that's a very
important
um uh sort of evolution of how we think
about these things
thank you Jack and before I go on to
Greg Smith he's asking the next round of
questions I'm just going to warn the
witnesses if you do answer in a very
elongated fashion I will cut you off and
ask your questions to ask the next
question is that okay we have a lot to
get through Greg
thank you chairman Secretary of State
the awesome statement made a big
commitment on East West rail
what is your understanding of what that
actually means is that the whole project
as it was originally conceived including
the Aylesbury spur or just Oxford
through to Cambridge
um so
the overall commitment that Chancellor
made I think was to set a very clear uh
impression given that he'd confirmed the
overall spending that the government was
still committed to that project
um for the and I think he's set out
subsequently that's the whole
um line from Oxford to Cambridge on your
specific question uh I'm going to I'm
either going to ask the perm reception
to come in a lot or I'm going to uh I'm
afraid I'm going to have to write to you
all the detail of that I I recognize the
complexity of these things and the
planning implications and I don't want
to get them wrong I don't know whether
Bernadette wants to add anything I think
it is safer to write I mean at the
moment thank you very much okay is it
still the intention to launch uh the
first part of east west rail which is
very nearly built on diesel only Rolling
Stock
uh I don't know the answer to that
question I think we are looking at the
question of the um Diesel and
electrification still in relation to
East West so I know quite a number of
decisions yet to be taken on on how that
will work so the question there is less
about electrification or not I think the
ship has sailed on that because most of
it's built by mode I think it's whether
it's buy load or hydrogen or whatever it
might be because as it stands with big
Net Zero commitments and the length of
the life of Rolling Stock at the moment
the plan is as I understand it to launch
with diesel that can't be a sensible
decision can it so that would be the
um stage one from Bletchley uh from
Bletchley to Milton Keynes I guess where
obviously we're much more advanced and
the uh construction is already underway
uh let me check with you exactly what
the Rolling Stock expectation is for
that section clearly for the later
stages through to Cambridge
um there are many more these are a much
earlier stage of development and the
question I think about the Rolling Stock
will be also at a much earlier stage of
development okay thank you
um perhaps more broadly
uh
East-West rail from Oxford to Bletchley
has brought an Old Railway Back to Life
Beyond Bletchley is a new cutting before
any work is done on starting Beyond
Bletchley towards Cambridge will you do
a full review of the lessons
particularly the impacts on communities
along the line of route
especially businesses
to understand what has gone wrong in the
construction of the first part
well we were always listen very
carefully to lessons I made a constant
part of our project delivery to to
reevaluate and learn lessons as we go
um I'd be very interested in following
up with Mr Smith exactly the problems
that you and local businesses have
experienced in talking to East West rail
about those and absolutely all of the
lessons from this stage one we will want
to fully process and ensure we're taking
into account in later stages
thank you that's all I have on rail I
want to turn to Road
uh particularly passenger vehicles at
the moment again in the Autumn statement
we saw uh fairness come back in the way
all vehicle types are taxed with
electric vehicles no longer getting a
freebie
I'm trying to transport feed into that
was that Holier treasury decision
well I think first of all the tax
measures as you know are matters for the
chancellor and I've got a trespass in
those I think the implementation of
vehicle excise duty
um I think is very sensible I don't
think it makes a significant difference
to purchasing decisions but it clearly
answers one question about vehicle
exercise Duty being available and that's
important for for the revenue that we
then get for investment in roads so I
think that's a a welcome decision but I
mean as you know Tax Matters are matters
for the chancellor my question was more
did the DFT feed into that process at
all but but within that perhaps I could
ask
the extent to which you believe the
roads budget for either Building New
Roads improving our existing roads
getting money to councils to manage the
roads they run will go up as a result of
more Vehicles paying vehicle excise duty
well I think as I said in answer to the
question earlier on the Autumn statement
I'm very pleased that we got our
spending review budgets confirmed one of
the things I'm doing at the moment
obviously is looking at the balance of
spending between a capital on Rail and
on roads I'm very conscious as I said
earlier that you know the the majority
of Journeys are taken undertaken on
roads and I want to make sure we invest
in our road Network both the Strategic
Network and what we provide for local
roads to make sure people can we can
keep the country moving both in terms of
passenger vehicles and also Freight that
that that's helpful do you think
looking at the dynamic again between
incentives that were previously offered
for people to buy EVS
that we are still on track for the 2030
ban on new petrol and Diesel
um I I do as you know part of the
challenge about how you deploy public
money is to do it in a way that
um gets us to a model where the private
sector can then take over so you know
the initial in incentives we put in
place for electric vehicles
um actually have done their their work
and we're seeing a very significant
uptake in electric vehicles as far as
passenger cars are confirmed
um one of the things the Department's
also got to do is look at how we
accelerate or deal with the gaps for
rolling out charging so there's a lot of
private investment going into charging
and there are some areas where the
department will put public money in to
make sure that we can continue rolling
that out but yes I think we I think we
are on track how much is the department
looking at other emerging Technologies
hydrogen direct hydrogen combustion
hydrogen fuel cells synthetic fuels on
top of EVS so I think the I think I'm
right in saying that the Department's
always been a technology neutral so the
objective is to get to our Net Zero
objectives but we're not wedded to
particular Technologies and I think um
Gareth said in one of his earlier
answers and when he was talking about
when we talk about the regulatory regime
actually we want to uh incentivize
companies to look at all of those things
so exactly what the share of those will
be going forward I mean that will depend
on the development of the technology and
the private investment but where it's a
technology neutral approach and clearly
I've already picked up in the time I've
been doing this job that for different
for different roles for different sorts
of vehicles there may well be different
Technology Solutions and we're very much
encouraging all of those I don't know
whether you want to add anything yeah I
think it's fair to say on cars it does
feel like the momentum's with electric I
think you've sort of seeing that on the
back of what Tesla have done in terms of
certainly the numbers we see of new car
sales you know 20 now have a plug in
November so you can see the momentum
going demand is not an issue we've taken
away some of the financial incentives
more the constraints are on the supply
side with the global disruption and
Supply chains particularly around chips
um Vans similarly look like moving
towards electric there's still a big
debate in trucks particularly over 26
tons will it be hydrogen fuel cells as
recently with Scania and they have some
very impressive electric trucks at very
large scales so you can see options
there we have got a series of Trials
running of both hydrogen the overhead
gantries and batteries to understand how
that will fit into the wider Logistics
sectors much more debate in Maritime and
Aviation Maritime at cop 26. it was an
interesting study published there which
showed actually of countries and
shipping companies around the world
still a mix of ammonia hydrogen
potentially even nuclear on Aviation
sustainable Aviation fuels and you
mentioned synthetic fuels very much seen
as a core technology for the next I was
going to call it a bridging technology
but this is sort of 30 years at least
given the asset Cycles question about
the role of hydrogen and quite how long
that will go battery planes and I
mentioned people like vertical Aerospace
before very interesting on the more
Shore hall for the UK domestic scene
that that's very interesting I want I do
want to keep these questions
specifically to passenger cars just for
a couple of more quick questions
there's a lot of focus
on the EV Market on the new sales from
2030 how much thought is being put into
how we keep all the other cars that are
on the road potentially up to 30 million
of them running
Beyond 2030 potentially in a Greener way
by which me I really do come back to the
synthetic fuel point
and how big of a priority is it to keep
those cars on the road rather than to
see Mass scrappage schemes or things
that will inevitably involve
taxpayer subsidy in order to help people
move on clearly clearly the legislative
priorities is on new vehicles and you're
right that and certainly from a carbon
point of view you have to balance those
Capital assets that have already been
produced you don't want them all being
scrapped too soon because actually
that's not great from a carbon emissions
point of view either
um I I've spent most of my time so far
looking at the the EV rollout for new
vehicles I don't know where they're
going to add anything otherwise
otherwise we'll write to you yeah
otherwise my main point would be in fact
we are conscious of the embedded carbon
in the vehicle stock on the road so it's
not just obviously there's a focus on
emissions uh at the tailpipe for
particularly around air quality reasons
as well but we're also looking at how we
manage the overall stock and ensure the
maintenance and improve the efficiency
the medium okay
my last area I want to talk about at
four roads is smart motorways these have
been a controversial subject for some
years now it was this committee's
recommendations that led to one of your
predecessors uh pausing the new rollout
but just last month we had a seven hour
outage on stop vehicle detection coming
up into what now see appears to be
strike season uh there is a there's been
media reports that those that the human
beings that monitor the technology for
stop vehicle detection May well be on
the strikers list
should we just go a bit further and
restore hard shoulders on all these
roads until we can be confident the
technology actually works secretary
coming into the role fresh what what is
your approach to smart motorways so
first of all I think it's worth saying
that I think the committee
um did a very good job I think on on the
the work that he did it certainly was
stuff that I paid attention to before I
came into this role I think the
commitment that my predecessors made I
think still stands which is about
pausing the roll out of the various
types of smart motorways until we've
collected a a larger series of of data
so I did that position hasn't changed I
think that's the position I'm
comfortable with maintaining on your
specific point um I'll set up what I
think the position is and no doubt
Bernadette will correct me on National
Highway staff those involved in
monitoring um all of our road Network
um you're right that there there have
been strikes announced I think the
number of Staff in National highways who
are members of the Trade union who may
well be striking as a relatively small
number one of the things the
Department's very experienced in is
managing those operational issues and
focusing resources on the most important
areas so I don't think we're
anticipating any significant issues from
a road safety perspective as a result of
any of the strike days that have been
announced and I think if if
that is exactly right I mean it's about
11 of national highway staff or PCS
members which is the Striking Union
about half of those voted for strike
action so National highways is not
expecting a sort of mass walk out of
staff on strike days and it has robust
contingency plans to deal with a strike
impacts and obviously it will be
prioritizing in those plans
um Road Safety activities so I think
some of the report has been somewhat
exaggerated about the impact on the road
Network
okay thank you chairman he's done that
Secretary of State I'm just going to ask
you very brutally do you believe smart
motorways are smart
smart or safe
well in terms of are they smart I've
looked at the I've looked at the
evidence on them that has been collected
so far I think it's very sensible of my
predecessors to say we're going to
collect more uh evidence
um I think we're we're going to be
publishing some statistics on safety uh
going forward I think one of the things
we have made a commitment about which
I'm very clear about we have got to take
the public with us on this so whatever
the data says people have to be
comfortable with them one of the things
one of the things we've set out is about
investing in more emergency areas on
those smart motorways that don't have
hard shoulders to reassure people but
I'm very clear there's a there's a point
about data and about facts but there's
also a point about making sure that
people feel safe and comfortable using
the various types of smart modes or
comfortable on a Motorway that you broke
down under the artificial intelligence
doesn't see your breakdown and notify
the human operator it waits for
congestion to mount up which can take
15-20 minutes before any human person
realizes there's a problem on a
so-called smart Motorway would you feel
safe with you and your family and I've
got well there are of course different
sorts of smart motorways on the specific
ones you refer to the all Lane running
ones yes you're right the the technology
clearly needs to be working properly and
Mr Smith highlighted one example where
there was a technology outage and those
are exactly that's why you need to
collect the data over a longer period so
I'm very clear that smart way to AIDS
have a lot of Advantage is but the
public absolutely has to be confidence
in using them
um even in scenarios which are
relatively infrequent we have to take
people with us and I think that's one of
the incredibly valuable things the
committee did in the work it took in the
work it did and the evidence it took was
to challenge government on that and I
think government responded and and I
think my predecessors made sensible
commitments on that and those
commitments that I maintain cue your
comments are noted Ruth your next thank
you chair
on by going back to electric vehicles
the government's committed to deliver at
least 300 000 charge points by
2030. if there's going to be no
transport legislation in this
parliamentary session is that
deliverable
um and uh if not what can be delivered
so uh on the charge points I don't think
that's something that's going to be
primarily delivered by legislation there
are two points I would say a lot of the
charge points are obviously going to be
delivered by private investment
in businesses investing in those in in
all sorts of things and we're seeing a
lot of that already there are clearly
areas where the taxpayer and my
department is going to have to intervene
one of those is to make sure we have a
proper network of charge points at
Motorway service areas and on the
Strategic Road Network the other areas
to work with local authorities on making
sure we see charging options for people
where they don't have any legislation
stuff no I don't believe it does it's
going to be a combination of private
investment and investment from the
taxpayer in the areas where you need
that extra support to make sure we
deliver the charging Network so that
Target is deliverable you can work there
I I believe the targets that we've set
out are deliverable and we're working at
PACE to make sure we can deliver them
thank you
Kevin yeah thanks so much chair with
regard to
um zero Mission buses
um it's been it has been about the thorn
issue for for the government since the
previous previous
previous prime minister made the his
four thousand bus pledge well I suppose
I'll start with that in your eyes
there's a four thousand bus pledge I
pledge for
um for England uh he's responsible for
are your responsible for now or was that
for the whole of the UK I think that was
a number for the whole of the UK and I
think if I remember correctly I think
we're we're up to about
3276 if I remember correctly but it was
it was a UK commitment I think the four
thousand when you see a few thousand uh
you're talking about money monies that
have been committed to
um local original authorities in England
because at the moment according to
written answer I received just a couple
weeks ago
um of the four thousand eighty seven are
on the roads in England another 425 uh
an order
um that's less than two and a half
percent Scotland is actually at 548 so
more 10 the size but more than than
England have in terms of actually being
ordered
um what do you make of that progress
well in terms of actual ordering and
procuring well in terms of in terms of
progress I mean I welcome might I don't
think there's particularly a competition
here between the different parts of the
United States
competition is fine and I think but I
think in terms of delivering the United
Kingdom's Net Zero commitment so I mean
frankly the more zero emission buses we
have delivered across the UK the fight
and I personally I'm very comfortable
with with different parts of the country
um delivering them I'm just looking at
the um
the the statistic yeah 3276 is the
number that I've got
um uh and we're we're continuing to
deliver them whether we quite get to 4
000 we'll see but that was a that was a
that was a UK number
due perhaps write to the committee to to
set up because you've got a different
figure than my written answer could you
perhaps see what has been what sort of
been ordered what is uh what's unload
what's been ordered and obviously what
monies have been
um
but also
um can you confirm if any money's last
question before I went back to Jared if
any money has been handed back
um from Regional or local authorities in
England to struggling to get operators
to
um to run said bushes yeah I think um
given it's a it's a fair bit of detail
you want I'm very happy to write to the
committee to set out those particular
aspects of it yeah all of those things
that you said let's do that Secretary of
State this is a quick question for you
thank you um
Secretary of State we have in this
country uh regulated Peak and off-peak
walk-up as that anyone should be able to
buy uh to get on any train within the
time frame
Avanti West Coast
and its retailers
do not sell those walk-up fares when it
suits them
have you or anyone in your department
authorized of anti-west coast
to do this and if you haven't would you
commit to a full investigation as to why
that train company is in effect
preventing off-peak train ticket sales
and selling tickets only allowing for
sale tickets at a higher price than the
off-peak regulated fare
it's a very detailed question Mr I'm
very happy to to instruct my officials
to investigate and I will write to the
committee to let the committee know
secretary
thank you um Secretary State you're a
very and welcome Lee mentioned active
travel in your introduction in terms of
your priorities
um can you update us on the signing off
of the fourth round of active travel
funding because there are about 1500
schemes waiting to go ahead around the
country and local authorities are very
keen to get this funding ASAP yes I'm
I'm well I'm pleased to mention it
because I was trying to give the the
sense that I'm I'm despite the fact that
we spend a lot of time talking about
Railways I'm very conscious that I want
to try and make sure the department is
the department for transport not the
department for trains and we reflect the
fact you know a third of the trips that
people make are are walking and and the
two percent are cycling so
um uh in answer to my question on the
Autumn statement I'm looking at the
spending of the department across the
range of modes which will include active
travel when we've concluded that we'll
be in a position then to
um to deal with the the Forefront of the
active travel funding give us some idea
when that might be it's just because the
the the the previous Secretary of State
before the last one had already signed
it off
um and then when when Anne-Marie
trevelyn came before us she said she had
to sign it off
um and now we're waiting for you to sign
it off so uh you know if you haven't had
your budget cut and you say this is a
priority
what is what is stopping you signing
this off so we've had our budgets
confirmed as we had in spending review
but you'll know that there there's a
very significant level of inflation
we're having to deal with the manage
across the department as other
government departments are and indeed
the private sector so we're having to
look at the priorities across the
department when I've concluded that
exercise which we're doing at PACE will
be in a position to make that
announcement but I'm not in a position
to do that today weeks months
well I'm conscious that we need to do it
early enough that people can then get
those funds and to deliver them
um so I'm doing it at the earliest
possible opportunities I'm not gonna I'm
not going to pluck a date out of thin
air and then and then disappoint the
committee what I will do is we've been
asked to set out a number of specifics
on the legislative program I will I will
see what we can do in terms of whether I
can give you a more specific answer and
we'll write to the committee and set
that out when when your parliamentary
colleague kit malthouse said on the
world at one on the 16th of November in
the context of the new fiscal event that
active travel was a nice to having good
times in implying that this is going to
be cut that's not your view
I think I think allowing uh putting
schemes in place that enable people to
walk uh more safely and easily and also
to use
um to cycle safely I think they are very
important
um but we're having to look at those
across the whole piece I'm very clear
and the reason why I mentioned it was
I'm very conscious about how people
travel and I want to make sure that the
decisions that we're taking deal with
inflation pressures don't unfairly
penalize any particular mode of
Transport is it is it still uh is is
active travel England's status as a
statutory consultee for major planning
applications still under threat this was
threatened by Simon Clark
and I'm not aware that that threat has
been withdrawn can you clarify for us
because not least Chris Borden will be
very interested in your answer I I I'm
not aware of of what Mr Clark set out
when he was a member of the government
he's obviously no longer a member of the
government on that specific question let
me let me find out and I'll let the
committee know
just just on the issue now I'm not sure
whether it's it's fair to expect to
expect you to know this level of detail
but perhaps again you could um give us
some information because as part of our
inquiries into Maritime 2050 and the
logistics supply chain the port of Dover
told us that they didn't know when they
would find out how the new EU entry exit
system checks that a Tudor come into
effect in May of next year
they didn't know how they would work I I
wonder if you could give some indication
as to as to where we stand with that and
and if if I may as well ask my my other
question also in relation to the
maritime sector that there have been
some criticisms about the seafarers
wages Bill we're all very concerned
about the appalling activities of of
pain or followed by other unscrupulous
employers
but we're we're concerned about how
International Agreements are going to be
affected and if there's a possibility of
circumventing the legislation by what's
being called poor topping and how can we
avoid that
okay so on your on your last point on
the seafarers wages bill which has
obviously been uh introduced into the
House of Commons
um I'm hoping for an imminent
announcement about when we're going to
get the second reading of of that bill
um on the specific issue you I mean the
bill obviously has a very specific
purpose to deal with
um shipping in UK territorial waters on
the specific point you raise I don't
have the answer to that I will find out
and write to the committee and also make
sure we have that when we debate second
reading of the legislation
um
on your uh Paul De Dover question so one
of the um of the first visit that I did
actually which was to go and visit the
Kent resilience forum and also the port
of Dover and Euro tunnel to talk about a
range of issues but also to talk about
the European system so it's fair to say
I think that the European Union hasn't
published a great deal of information
about how this is going to work my those
the concerns about that were raised by
all of the stakeholders my department is
working closely with the port
with other parts of the UK government
but also working closely with the
European commission and the French
government to try and understand how
this is going to be implemented and what
the requirements are going to be on us
and particularly at the juxtaposed
controls and that work is underway but
obviously it's a European Union system
and they need to tell us how what the
requirement is going to be and we will
obviously then work to comply with them
and work with the port and if you've met
met with the Kent resilience forum and
the port of doorbell you'll understand
their concerns about the logistics
supply chain and so on when did you have
that meeting just said of curiosity was
it recently it was it was a couple of
weeks ago yeah all right okay thanks
cheers
um secretary just before I move on to
Gavin next I'm conscious that you are
going to be inviting to us with answers
and details on various different
subjects and I'm conscious that your two
permanent secretaries are sitting right
next door to you so as a matter of
process you don't have to write to us
just with one letter do let us have the
information as it becomes available if
that's okay is that all right always as
you know seek to
um provide the swiftest possible and
fullest possible responses to the
committee very happy to receive a number
of different letters from you and your
department so Gary
yeah thanks so much cheers
telling to
decarbonization again
um and looking back to cup 26 with the
Clyde Bank
um declaration they make copper 26 so in
terms of progress will the UK have a
green shipping quarter by 2025.
um so we as you know we made a um
commitment at cot working with some of
our
um Global Partners about that
um green shipping Corridor there were 24
countries of um committed to supporting
the establishment of those
um and where um we're trying to work and
Lead that that work
um I think the uh what do you want to
add anything specific on the timing no I
think the timing it will take longer
than 2025 as you say because in terms of
but you'll work through both the actual
ships the port Technologies as well and
when but in terms of progress we saw a
cop 27 it was pretty impressive the
number of countries that are leaning
into this now we've got agreements with
the US Norway and the Netherlands
um similarly the department has put in
already 34 million pound into over 80
projects across the UK around the clear
Maritime demonstrations this is about
getting the port side technology right
but I think we shouldn't underestimate
the scale of the challenge that get the
green shipping corridors right but that
is a big Focus for the Department of the
secretary of state has said and
obviously it's not in your gift or your
control because obviously it's
International and whatnot what was
what would be your best estimate as to
when we could when you'd hope to have uh
the first green shipping card on please
um
I'm balancing between being optimistic
and not wanting to disappoint you on
this one I think I'll play back the
answer a number of people made a cop 27
to give you a sense of where the
International Community is on this they
were saying so the back end of this
decade that was where they thought they
would be fully operational before that I
would expect to see Pilots running and
particularly around I'm interested in
what's going on back to Dover on the
short straights and some of the routes
and I think actually again outside of
this country the U.S uh uh Singapore
links are actually really interesting
but it's going to be second half of this
decade will be my expectation where you
see real progress one of the important
things we are working on is to build the
International Coalition on the back of
cop both 26 and 27 at the IMO to have
the focus there on zero emissions and
building that Coalition just as we have
done uh with International Aviation
emissions yeah and just before I move on
to Aviation
um just voted to bring shipping
emissions into its Cabin Market
including International voyages and does
the UK plan to do something similar
I come in carbon budget six for the UK
which is the 20 around 2035 will include
I think we've announced this previously
International Aviation and shipping
Admissions and even to date what we do
is when we have the carbon budgets we
make an allowance for international
admissions so they are in effect a
counter foreign system isn't this is not
sort of an off book set of numbers so
okay moving on to Aviation and I'll come
back and touch on
emotions but in terms of aviation in
general as Secretary of State are you
confident now given I haven't gone
through the Airlines and airports have
the Staffing capacity uh to avoid the
repute of the disruption we've seen this
summer and to something you're obviously
still continue to see but uh not not to
the same degree yeah I think following
what happened this summer I think we've
done a lot of work with
um both airports and Airlines about
testing and and challenging them on
their resilience and I think the work
that we've done particularly talking to
them about
um The Christmas and winter period I
think we're we're confident or you know
we've tested their plans and I think
they've dealt with some of the issues
that they had during the summer and the
the big challenge of course coming back
to some of my previous answers is of
course in we are expecting because the
unions have suggested that there may
well be some industrial action uh on the
in the aviation sector both for public
employees and those working for airports
and Airlines and that will clearly have
an impact and airports and Airlines will
have to respond accordingly but in terms
of their base processes I think there's
been a lot of work done since the summer
to try and avoid that disruption that we
saw yeah and some lot of disruption was
caused in or by the ground handling
sector which of course is one of the of
the lowest paid parts of the aviation
sector and
um there's supposed to be a review of
the groundhog Market you know he threw
themselves are looking for reviewing
ground handling at the airport but the
government will look at Ground handling
so we're argue with with reviewing and I
know there's been different teams at DFT
but we're told they were reviewing it so
are you aware of any progressions no no
that commitment was one was given you
know before I came into space the
reviews ongoing at the moment and we're
looking to have the report ready for the
Secretary of State in the early New Year
Nearly New Year yeah early New Year okay
thanks inter in terms of the recovery
itself in the sector
um as many of us have warned and
obviously as we've seen with other
downtown's navigation the recovery is
always an equal so you'll see Heathrow
come back a lot quicker than
um than Regional airports and we've seen
the same with Glasgow Glasgow for
instance still 70 of 2019 levels what do
you plan to do as a department to try
and assist we've seen no addition to
Doncaster obviously what are you going
to do to assist airports like Glasgow
like Newcastle
um etc etc to recover because jobs are
an issue
um at these airports well they are I
mean look to some extent we've seen
we've seen significant changes in travel
patterns um post covid and I I think we
I think actually my experience looking
at the travel set we shouldn't just
assume that things are going to go back
how they were before I mean people have
now made certainly as far as businesses
are concerned people are now able to do
things that they weren't previously able
to do they're prepared to do things
before we've seen changes in business
travel and international travel so I
think the government will do what we can
if there are barriers that are in place
that we need to look at we'll look at
those but to some at some extent some of
this works going to be done by Airlines
and airports looking at passenger
experience looking at different travel
patterns looking at responding to their
services to meet the changing needs of
both business and Leisure Travelers I
don't think I think just assuming things
are going to flip back to what they were
before or I don't think is necessarily
the right assumption
a large part of this piece will be
um Regional connectivity which is which
is another issue we've been trying to
push the government to
um to respond on but uh previously we've
spoken about our previous reports from
this committee spoke about psos uh and
perhaps that more psos might be required
um to to generate that Revival as well
as as well as providing more
connectivity all the psos currently in
the UK government support are to and
from London and that was a change we
were advising it should make is that
something you'd be looking to
um to look at in the coming months on
the public service obligations I I've
certainly got on I've got an open mind
about those I think you have to look at
those on a case-by-case basis it's about
the the the the need balancing the need
against the cost to the taxpayer so I
don't have a closed mind about those
where we judge that they're necessary
and and you'll you know the need and the
cost
there's a sensible balance and I think
we're perfectly happy to take those on a
case-by-case basis so I wouldn't want to
you know give you a
a general answer it will look at the
specific circumstances but we're
certainly open to looking at them okay
we've seen uh reports depressed recently
and there may be changes coming or
changes of foot with regard to liquids
and hand luggage perhaps in 2024 is this
correct
well obviously we um continue to keep
these things under review there are a
number of Pilots going on about looking
at new technology and how you deal with
that if there are any changes that are
going to take place
um more widely then obviously we'll make
announcements in due course still we'll
have to be clear Communications around
those obviously for to make sure
passengers know what's going on so if we
announce any of those we will do those
in a in a proper way announce them
properly with clear Communications for
people
um as I said when we've learned the
lessons of the pilots that are that are
being undertaken and if that says to be
a mandated change and giving what I said
in the previous question might there be
support available for some airports
um to make this change if it's a
government mandate well if there are any
changes in requirements that we make we
will we will do those in the usual way
but I think we're leaping ahead of
ourselves here when we make
announcements we will do those in the
usual way
um and we'll set out what our
expectations are and what the
responsibilities are of of the
government but also of the private
sector Partners okay and last lastly
from from the issue of
of decarbonization which obviously is
tougher for aviation in any other sector
um
but
um the easiest thing we can do in the
crackiest thing we can do is airspace
modernization so
are you pleased with current progress
um
um so I mean I think the one of the
issues we've had with airspace
modernization over the last two years
obviously has been the impact on the
finances of the industry this has been
primarily funded by the airports and
obviously we've had to go slower than we
might want it to
um due to their impact disability fund
it we have put in as a government
um best part of 10 million pounds of
fund some airspace modernization and we
see this as this can seem like quite a
technical issue but obviously as you you
reflect on it's about you might save up
to 10 to 15 percent of aircraft carbon
emissions by modernizing airspace I
think the free route airspace in
Scotland has been incredible success and
we want to build on that on that lesson
um we've asked the CAA to come forward
with an updated airspace modernization
plan and they're due to do that in the
early New Year
yeah from what I understand it would
perhaps you want to take a government
investment around 20 million pounds to
get this to perhaps get this done names
are not something you'd consider
uh well certainly once I once we get the
report from the CAA we'll absolutely
look at what if there are any Financial
consequences we'll absolutely look at
them and we'll look at what the you know
and have to balance those off against
the other priorities but I'm certainly
certainly very keen to look at what the
CAA bring forward okay and it says last
question the other
achievable method or to decarbonization
that's that's within reach a sustainable
Aviation fuels
um so the government obviously feel that
aware of that there's a commitment for
five plants I think or to be under
construction by uh 2025 and a staff
mandate
um by I think 23 of 10 is the from from
memory but the current plans would only
have the current plans for sites would
only produce five percent
um instead of 10 so there's results a
lot more work to do
um
would you consider as this committee has
suggested
um
previously
um looking at a patient support
mechanism such as a cfd type model for
sustained evaluation fields
so your what you've said
um Mr Dunes in terms of the commitments
um are correct and I'll ask Gareth just
to set up on the cfd I'm very conscious
the industry is very interested in the
idea of having some sort of contract for
difference mechanism to support
um the growth of a sustainable aviation
fuel so as you say we've got the demand
side incentive through the through the
mandates which is really important I
think the big question now is can you
also get the industrial benefits the
Mandate will ensure we reduce carbon
emissions but can you actually get the
industrial benefits and I think for me
the strength of the UK chemical industry
suggests there's a real compared
potential comparative advantage here
we've put in as a government 165 million
pound of startup funding for some of the
plants
um contract for differences obviously
there's an attraction around that and
that was being this thing that's been
used on solar and offshore from memory
the risk is if you get this wrong it's
incredibly expensive for the taxpayers
and you've got to get the calibration of
that entirely right and given the wider
pressures on the public finances it's
important that yes we look at it and we
are looking at it within
but also is recognize actually the value
for money questions for the taxpayer on
this
and actually in fact the dingers we've
made for behind the rest of the world if
we if we don't progress uh with cfd
enemy Jim well um thank you very much
Gareth and Secretary of State and before
I come to Ruth I just like to
congratulate my colleague on getting
three final questions in
um Ruth I'm conscious we hopefully
secretary say we'll maybe overrun for
about 10 minutes so maybe 20 to 12 will
finish Ruth
Secretary of State given the
the ancient and also constrained carbon
budgets that are coming in do you still
support the expansion of Heathrow
Airport and Bristol Airport
so um
I'm just conscious on on Heathrow the
complexity of the
legal position there and I don't want to
um jump into that but look
I'm very conscious that we are on the
issue about
um
Bristol airport and and he's right
Bristol I know there's a planning issue
going on at the moment I'm just very
conscious I don't want to to dive into
those and cause any legal difficulties
so I've asked them
permanent secretary should I say
something on the Heathrow I mean look
here at the the legal situations as is
as it was
um there was a series of court cases I'm
sorry I'll forget the year now because
of covid but it's probably 2019 2020
that we work through various challenges
um
the national airspace planning system is
now in place it's up for Heathrow this
has always been I think it was said in
the manifesto a private sector promoted
scheme it's up for Heathrow then to come
forward with plans for how they want to
do that obviously given the impact on
their finances of covert that's been on
hold and we've yet to have conversations
with Heathrow
um whether where their position is on
this one more generally I think we're
looking at what the forecast for
Aviation numbers will be which is
obviously the heart of the of the
planning statement and the assessment to
date has been it's continued uncertainty
in the aviation Market means it's hard
to make future forecasts and we're
waiting for the market to settle down
before we then come forward to the
future forecast didn't answer about the
carbon budgets so that's the horse the
carbon budget question is basically
because previously the assessment for
the planning statement was made when we
pre The Net Zero commitment from the
government so once we understand the
nature of future demand or at least the
uncertainties comes in will then be the
opportunity for the Secretary of State
then to review the planning guidance
thousands of people in this country were
deprived of their legal right to
compensation when their flights were
disrupted or canceled over the last year
when are you going to give the CAA the
powers that it needs to ensure that
Airlines obey the law and the powers of
this committee is called for it to be
given repeatedly for many years
so um this is one of the questions I've
had some my introductory meetings with
the CAA chairman and chief executive
um and their ability to intervene in the
consumer space is one of the things I'm
looking at very closely so it's one of
the things I've I've discussed with them
um I'm not able to give you a specific
timetable it's maybe one of the things I
can set out in writing um for the
committee lovely and in principle do you
think it would be wrong to water down
the British Public's current right to
compensation when their domestic or into
European flights are disrupted
so I'm very keen that I want to make
sure that we continue to protect
consumers and I want to make sure that
the regime for Consumer Protection you
know continues to deliver you know what
we think is right I want to look at that
I mean see whether we can improve it
um maintain it or or alter it in any way
but I'm very clear that we want to
protect consumers and give them
confidence thank you thank you that's
Secretary of State uh Jack burrison has
some questions for you on buses thank
you chair and obviously the pandemics
had a massive impact on local bus
services and public transport more
generally so what is your vision for the
future of bus
so I'm glad you've asked that question I
touched on it in my earlier remarks and
I wanted to mention it to make sure that
um you knew it was a priority so one of
the things that came up at my first set
of oral questions lots of questions
about buses particularly the investment
that the government's made in a bus
service improvement plans
um a lot of the money that we've done in
the city region deals have had a bus
component to them as well and I'm also
very conscious that the challenges that
bus services have had
um with covid and the postcovid period
And I know in my my own constituencies
there are some real challenges in
delivering sustainable bus services
particularly in rural areas one of the
things I'm very pleased that the
Department's doing as well as the
funding that we're delivering is some of
the pilots that we're doing about how
you can deliver bus services in a way
that's more sustainable so for example
in my own constituency delivered before
I was Secretary of State there are some
pilots on demand responsive transport in
two parts of of gloucestershire and I'm
looking forward to seeing the evidence
from those so I'm very supportive of of
buses I'm very supportive of
us looking at how we can grow bus
ridership you know it's still still a
significant lower level than it was
pre-covered and I want to work with
local authorities
having those ambitious plans to grow bus
ridership in the future and the
government will look at what we can do
to support them as you say there's been
a massive struggle to try and get bus
ridership back to pre-pandemic levels so
is it still your and the Department's
view that we want to get bus ridership
up above pre-pandemic levels I mean
where exactly it comes to is obviously
going to be a decision for for
individuals but I do think we want to
grow bus ridership
um higher than it is at the moment and
clearly you know get it back to the sort
of levels we were looking at so that's
why the I think the bus Improvement
um bus service improvement plans that
we've been doing have we've tried to
encourage local authorities to have
ambitious plans to grow bus ridership
one of the things I briefly talked about
when I talked to Northern Mayors on my
visit we will come back to you we spent
a lot of time talking about trains I had
some very good conversations with Andy
Street about his plans for for buses in
the West Midlands so I'm very keen that
we work with local authorities who have
ambitious plans on growing bus ridership
and also look at different models one of
the advantages of devolution is we can
look at different ways of of managing
bus services in different areas to try
and grow the ridership
um have a more modern bus
and make them easier for people to use
and also join up transport opportunities
across different modes and having better
ticketing opportunities for people
um so they'll give people more choices
hey Jack Chris
thanks Mr chairman uh finally
um Secretary of State for me what makes
will you bring in to support the local
authorities that missed out on the
funding through the bus service
improvement plan options places such as
Dorset buckinghamshire and others that
have very few Services now as
so I was very clear and it again came
through very clearly from from
colleagues that raised these questions
at our oral question session that they
were there's a lot of unfulfilled demand
people that bid for had quite ambitious
plans for for uh by service improvement
plans that we couldn't fund so I'm very
conscious as we work through our Autumn
statement uh work that I want to make
sure we've got an appropriate level of
funding
um for bus services in the future so
that we can continue to have those
opportunities to come forward are there
any specific measures that you're
looking to implement any any exciting
initiatives to to bring buses well we've
got we've obviously got in the first
part of the Year you'll be aware of the
between January and March we've got the
two pound bus fare to try and deliver
um again an improvement in ridership
um in the first three months of next
year and I'm looking at what
opportunities we can have to continue to
have opportunities for local authorities
to bring forward ambitious plans
um and we'll be able to set more out
when we finalized our work on our
awesome statement so as it stands today
a number of Rural counties
from March looked looked to lose
um quite a lot of their bus services for
the few that we have as it stands today
there are no measures in place
from the 1st of March to basically bring
bus services back or to do some exciting
things to bring bus services to those
who need them so I'm clearly very well
aware of some of the money that we've
put into supporting bus services post
covered specifically focused on that
those run out at the end of March I'm
very clear that I want to make sure we
continue supporting bus services so one
of the things I've tasked my team to do
as we work through
the financial settlement from the Autumn
statement is what's the right level of
support that the department needs to
continue doing for buses and what sorts
of things do we need to continue doing
so
um the absence of
having said something today I don't
think should be read either way I'm very
conscious we'll need to say more about
buses in the near future previously
we've had a number of quite difficult
sessions with Marina sphere when she was
Minister for buses
um and I think it's fair to say that we
took evidence from a number of Rural
County councils that did show that there
was not a very satisfactory relationship
between County councils and the
department would you today commit to
hold a summit with leaders of County
Rural County councils certainly across
England and maybe further afield in
order to get their feedback first hand
so you can actually maybe take some of
their ideas and suggestions to uh to
draw forward well look I think I think
two things first of all I'm very well
aware because of the parts of the
country I represent I'm a member of
parliament in Forester Dean which is a
rural part of gloucestershire which is a
broadly rural County I think my
constituency has some of the challenges
which I suspect I share with yours about
how do you deliver a a good bus service
in a rural area where you obviously
don't have the level of of ridership
that you'll have in a more urban area
and there are some challenges about
doing that in a sustainable way that's
exactly why the Department's looking at
some of these innovative ways of
delivering bus services so in terms of
your of interacting with local
authorities I I don't want to
immediately leap to a summit as a
solution but I'm very open to that so
let me let me go away and look at what
work we were already doing with local
authorities
um I'm very committed to
improving the engagement we have with
local authorities particularly those in
rural areas but um let me just not leap
to a particular solution but I will look
at what things we can do going forward
certainly not closing my mind to that
solution
thank you Chris Secretary State just a
few closing questions
um on buses what is the department doing
I know this is before your time so you
might want to write to us what is the
department doing with the bus service
network reviews that local transport
authorities were required to submit by
July
one of the things we haven't touched on
today
um is Road haulage and drivers driver
facilities and the planning regime
that's in place currently that negates
improving the lot for Road all his
drivers would you like to give us an
update on that rather than answer
something now as well as on your
thoughts on the supply chain and any
issues that have been apparent over the
past two three years and moving forward
over the next two I'll we'll write you
with a fuller answer but you you may be
aware of of what um Richard Holden the
rose Minister set out last week and set
out some
um support that we've made available to
improve the facilities for hdv drivers
which I think is really important and
we've obviously done a lot of work with
the industry on on making sure we can
make more tests available so that
actually we can increase the number of
HD hdv drivers to deal with the shortage
we saw we've made good progress on that
it's not it's not done yet but we've
made good progress and that maybe we'll
give some more information about that
when we write to the committee I don't
know whether Bernadette wants to add
anything now um just to say that I think
actually we've made good progress as
you'll recall last year
um uh we had a sort of 33 Point action
plan I think to deal with a then quiet
pressing issue of HEB driver shortages
of which
um uh the testing was a key part I think
we have made good progress I think the
industry is now reporting a much
improved situation in terms of
availability of hgv drivers so I think
we're feeling uh more confident about
that I think your questions may also
refer to our future plans for Freight
Beyond it specifically Drive facilities
I know the government has made some
monies available which has been welcome
indeed but I can see the planning regime
is the real is the real roadblock okay
so it's a planning machine
okay and
Bernadette dvla yes
um are there any any things you'd like
any Salient points you'd like to make
the committee aware of have there been
any further improvements I think as you
now
the dvla have now addressed all of the
backlogs the one remaining area of
difficulty is drivers Medicals which is
an important area I and the CEO and my
director General responsible for this
area gave evidence to the Public
Accounts committee a couple of weeks ago
on this and I'm I refer you to that I
think it's an exhaustive session with
many questions
um and I think a lot of progress has
been made as that as I hope our
testimony
um demonstrated I do think what it also
what we also
um acknowledged is that there are still
significant challenges around drivers
medical partly that's dealing with the
backlog but I think there is
um a prospect we do expect that to have
been addressed by the beginning of the
new year but I think uh what the
committee uh identified correctly was as
a sort of wider systemic issue it this
is a really challenging area of the
dvla's work partly because of the nature
of an aging population with multiple
medical conditions who naturally want to
continue to drive live but we need to
find a system capable of dealing with
those cases I think in a more effective
way and that is certainly something that
I and my colleagues in dvla are looking
very hard at but I think on the whole
um I believe that the dvla
notwithstanding the challenging uh
hearings is faced here in the past has
done really a good job of addressing the
backlogs that were created during the
pandemic so specifically for you
Secretary of State mots and the regime
in this country if it's not broke does
it need fixing
um well you know my
predecessor made some commitments there
I'm very focused on
I think
for me it's about outcomes it's about
making sure we have
um safe vehicles on the road so I will
continue to keep that under review and
looking what the evidence tells us
um I'm a great fan of it as you said if
it's not broke don't fix it but if there
are genuine things that we do need to
change and there's good evidence
supporting them and I'm very open to
doing that as well okay Jack you might
have had another question no we haven't
been just just to clarify the confusion
over the legislation earlier the the
last transport secretary did tell this
Committee in October that she was
continuing to pitch for a narrow bill
that would address some of those issues
just to clear that up but Dane
Bernadette seemed to have forgotten that
although she was here so what changed
did you decide to stop pitching or oh um
so on that specific thing so I don't I
don't think we were necessarily at Cross
purposes there I think I thought when
you asked me the question you said that
she'd confirmed that she was going to
bring forward a bill
um what you what you're now saying is
she was pitching for it my understanding
is the position when I took over this
role was that there isn't a legislative
slot for a transport bill in the third
session and that's that's not going to
take place I think that is right we look
forward to the very full written but
we'll set that out we'll set that out
comprehensively when we write Secretary
of State your colleagues as well thank
you very much indeed for what has been a
lengthy session at times should we say
feisty
but I think we all got our points across
and really for us it's to get
information from you and I think you've
imparted quite a lot thank you very much
thank you very much thank you
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended